- Wait, are you a superhero nerd like me?
- Yeah. I'm like, I'm like geeking out.
- I'm so excited.
I'm being lo real low key about it.
- Yeah. I'm like, I need to get on you.
I'm like really trying to hold it in.
- I know.
- Like, the Wasp right there.
- I know, do you have
anything you wanna ask?
- Yeah. Okay.
So, I didn't bring my notebook.
- [Evangeline] I'm here
for you. What do you need?
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So, as I'm a big comic book fan.
- All right.
- I've been reading comic
books since I was a kid
and a big thing for all of us nerds
is when characters constantly interact.
- Yeah.
- So for you, the Wasp, you
know, she's been with Ant Man
but I would like to know if
you had to like do another film
with another random hero,
team up with somebody else
and do that movie, because
that happens all the time
in the comics.
- That's a great question.
- Who would you do it with?
(chuckles)
- Well, not it, it could be it
or it could just be the movie.
- [Jonathan] Or the movie.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- What's your choice? Yeah.
- I'm gonna say that
it'd be really cool to do
even though normally I'm really down
on DC I'm just gonna be honest here.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Just really down on them.
- But like a Wonder Woman was
- Ooh
- Crossover. Where like DC meets Marvel.
- Wow. I don't know if
the world could take that.
- I could take it.
(crowd laughs)
- It's a sick choice. Okay.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Wouldn't you wanna do a
movie with Wonder Woman?
- [Jonathan] I mean.
- Come on now. Get out.
(crowd laughs)
- Do you just wanna be
in a scene with her?
- If I could, if I could
walk on set and say hi
and then like walk off, I would do that.
- Yeah, you'd be content.
- I don't know if you'd want to, man
I met her once time and I was like,
I don't know that I've ever
felt inferior in my life,
- Oh yeah.
- But I was like,
were we supposed to come out like that?
Like it was like.
- Yeah, like I didn't get the memo.
- It's Crazy Tall Goddess Vibes.
I was like, okay. Anyway.